y
[Música]
en colombia la comisión de la verdad
creada en el acuerdo de paz se reunió a
dos actores clave del conflicto el ex
jefe de los paramilitares salvatore
mancuso y el ex guerrillero rodrigo
londoño alias timochenko ambos hablaron
sobre su responsabilidad en los crímenes
cometidos durante el conflicto armado y
pidieron perdón
el gobierno mexicano presentó una
demanda a 11 empresas de armas en eeuu
por presuntamente facilitar el tráfico
ilegal hacia su territorio el documento
presentado en un tribunal federal de
massachusetts alega que fabricantes y
proveedores inundan el mercado con
armamento atractivo para los cárteles
continúa la persecución política en
nicaragua la última en quedar fuera de
la carrera electoral fue la ex reina de
belleza aprendices quesada que aspiraba
a la vicepresidencia con ella ya son 32
los líderes y dirigentes opositores
detenidos entre ellos siete aspirantes a
la presidencia
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco y como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos
en colombia porque en un acto virtual la
comisión de la verdad que forma parte de
la justicia transicional reunió a
timochenko ex líder de la guerrilla de
las farc y a salvatore mancuso ex líder
paramilitar para asumir las
responsabilidades y pedir perdón
mancuso solicitó ser testigo en el caso
de ejecuciones de civiles conocidas como
falsos positivos este acto es resultado
de los acuerdos de paz de 2016 entre el
estado y las farc tras más de 50 años de
conflicto informáticos niños sólo
hombres que se le están jugando el todo
por la paz continúan los esfuerzos para
conocer la verdad de la guerra en
colombia y el miércoles vivió un día
histórico
rodrigo londoño alias timochenko ex jefe
de la guerrilla de las farc y salvatore
mancuso ex jefe de los paramilitares de
las autodefensas unidas de colombia
reconocieron responsabilidades y
pidieron juntos perdón al país pues yo
no no tengo un problema en seguirlo
reiterando y sé que eso va a tocar hasta
el último día de mi existencia
mancuso quien está preso en una cárcel
de eeuu ha pedido ser aceptado en el
tribunal especial está a la espera de
ser trasladado a colombia donde le
señalan de coordinar más de un centenar
de masacres mancuso habló de la
responsabilidad del estado en las
muertes de líderes de izquierda y
sindicalistas la upe no fue exterminada
por para salvo que es su gran victimario
huele a columbia la comisión de la
verdad forma parte del sistema integral
para la paz junto a la justicia especial
para la paz y la unidad de búsqueda de
personas dadas por desaparecidas surgió
tras los acuerdos de paz entre el estado
y las farc en 2016
ante la comisión ya han comparecido tres
ex presidentes y ha juntado a víctimas y
victimarios en un conflicto de más de
medio siglo que ha causado más de 9
millones de víctimas quien dio la orden
tiene fueron esos políticos que todavía
están en línea delgadita pero no sabemos
sus nombres pese a los esfuerzos el
conflicto no termina colombia vive el
auge de las disidencias
guerrilla y los paramilitares además de
otros grupos armados que dejan más de
1200 asesinatos de líderes sociales y ex
combatientes desde los acuerdos de paz
de 2016
vamos hasta méxico donde el gobierno
demandó a 11 fabricantes y
distribuidores de armas estadounidenses
en un tribunal federal de boston con el
argumento de que sus prácticas
comerciales consideradas negligentes e
ilegales han provocado un gran
derramamiento de sangre en su territorio
este proceso podría durar años y el país
también espera una compensación
económica millonaria por parte de estas
empresas según datos del ejecutivo
mexicano cada año se trafican
ilegalmente más de quinientas mil armas
desde eeuu y sólo en 2019 fueron
responsables de más de 17.000 homicidios
dolosos en mexico el gobierno de lópez
obrador especificó que no se trata de
una demanda en contra del ejecutivo al
que reconoció su esfuerzo por tratar de
detener el tráfico ilícito de armas
primero que las empresas demandadas
compensan al gobierno de mexico por los
daños causados por sus prácticas
negligentes
el monto de esta exigencia será
determinado en el juicio
que desarrollen e implementen estándares
razonables verificables para monitorear
y en su caso disciplinar a sus
distribuidores
vamos a américa central porque en
nicaragua la noticia sigue siendo las
detenciones de opositores y
especialmente las de quienes aspiran a
enfrentar al presidente daniel ortega el
más reciente caso es el de la candidata
a la vicepresidencia berenice quezada a
quien el ministerio público ordenó
arrestar y le prohibió aspirar a cargos
públicos acusándola de apología al
delito de incitación al odio para hablar
de este tema estamos con israel- levitas
es un ingeniero ambiental nicaragüense
que es activista político y que está
exiliado ahora en panamá señor ley des
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
francés 24 porque acusan a quesada de
sus cargos que fue lo que dijo
en nicaragua estamos en un estado donde
se ha criminalizado a la oposición por
lo tanto cualquier persona que aspira un
cargo público y no sea un incondicional
de régimen inmediatamente de sal
inventar carlos lo de vélez dice quesada
es absolutamente ridículo al igual que
las acusaciones de los otros siete
precandidatos spears a la presidencia
ahora usted denunció la violencia por
parte de las fuerzas de seguridad en las
elecciones de 2006 en las que su tío el
sandinista haiti y leites fue candidato
en las de 2011 y 2016 que hay de
distinto en esta contienda electoral de
este año
el 2018 en nicaragua tuvimos un
levantamiento social que terminó más en
el asesinato de más de 328 personas y un
reporte de expertos internacionales en
donde la dictadura de ortega fue no sólo
acusadas se demostraron sus crímenes de
lesa humanidad desde entonces el país ha
vendido una deriva autoritaria y lo que
estamos viendo es cómo se va agudizando
cada vez más y estamos frente a un
proceso ilegal ilegítimo en donde el
dictador se está auto reeligiendo y la
comunidad internacional nos pasó de
comunicados pero seguimos esperando algo
sólido en medio de una organización
criminal como es el francés activista
que simplemente se ha tomado al estado
nicaragüense ahora israel llevan al
menos 32 líderes opositores detenidos en
el marco de las elecciones generales de
noviembre incluidos siete precandidatos
presidenciales la mayoría de ellos están
acusados de la nueva ley
10 55 y que consiste esta norma y cómo
está impactando las elecciones
la dictadura ha generado un tridente de
leyes represivas que son totalmente
genéricas se habla por ejemplo que es
prohibido aplaudir cualquier sanción en
contra con funcionario de la dictadura o
sea escucharme es prohibido aplaudir en
nicaragua bajo esta serie de leyes
espurias cualquier ciudadano que exprese
su criterio y esto no le parezca
correcto a la dictadura ya es sujeto de
ir a prisión israel como el panorama de
aquí a noviembre que va a pasar en grave
pues creo que más de lo mismo represión
y creo que es necesario es urgente que
la comunidad internacional desconozca
desde ya este proceso electoral porque
una elección no es un día de votación
una elección es todo un proceso y
nicaragua se han violado absolutamente
todas las normas que requiere un proceso
electoral esto es sin precedente lo que
está ocurriendo allá y necesitamos que
la comunidad internacional tenga también
una reacción sin precedentes no bastan
los comunicados necesitamos acciones
concretas en contra la dictadura de
daniel ortega nos están matando nos
están secuestrando nos han quitado
nuestro derecho a elegir y qué es lo que
quieren que el pueblo canadiense entre a
otra guerra civil por favor le hacemos
un llamado a la comunidad internacional
a los pueblos de otros países apoyen
israel gracias por su tiempo y por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 que tenga
usted un feliz resto de día nosotros
continuamos con más información la
justicia brasileña ordenó investigar al
presidente de aer bolsonaro
dar noticias falsas sobre las elecciones
tras varias semanas de ataques contra el
sistema de votación y asegurar que con
el voto electrónico se puede cometer
fraude
el magistrado alexandre de moral de la
corte suprema- atendió una solicitud
planteada por el tribunal superior
electoral fundamentado en la campaña de
descrédito que el mandatario ha desatado
contra las urnas electrónicas usadas en
los comicios de brasil desde el año 1996
vamos ahora hasta cuba donde sólo este
miércoles se registraron 98 muertes a
causa del coi 19 una cifra récord en la
isla desde el inicio de esta pandemia
pese a la vacunación en el país también
enfrenta un significativo aumento de los
casos identificados principalmente en la
provincia de ciego de ávila en el centro
de cuba
este hotel ubicado en el centro de cuba
cuenta habitualmente con una alta
ocupación en este periodo del año pero
esta vez los turistas fueron
reemplazados por personas contagiadas
con kobe el establecimiento se
transformó en un centro hospitalario y
enfrenta desde hace varios días un flujo
incesante de pacientes los contagios
están disparados en la provincia de
ciego de ávila y las autoridades han
registrado casi 100 fallecimientos en
tan solo 24 horas la isla acumula más de
3 mil decesos desde el inicio de la
pandemia la tasa de incidencia en la
isla con una población de 11.2 millones
de personas es de 1.141 personas por
cada 100.000 habitantes la situación
está complicada en el cub a esto debido
a
la variante venta que ha sido reportada
por las autoridades en varios lugares
del país que hay todavía una cantidad
significativa de población susceptibles
mientras tanto las autoridades inoculan
a la población apresuradamente las dos
vacunas más desarrolladas
abdalá y soberana comenzaron a ser
utilizadas incluso antes de ser
homologadas la primera tendría una
eficacia contra el comités y nueve de
más del 92% después de tres dosis según
el gobierno
un momento de pico pero que realmente va
disminuyendo progresivamente todas las
personas hasta que lleguemos ya la
ansiedad a memoria de pruebas ya la
inmunidad de rebaño que estamos buscando
que a su vez lo estamos haciendo a
través de la vacunación la isla bajo
sanciones estadounidenses trabaja con
sus propias vacunas que corresponden al
80 por ciento de su programa de
inmunización
el líbano miles de personas se
manifestaron en contra de la impunidad
por parte de las autoridades tras la
explosión en el puerto de beirut el 4 de
agosto del año pasado 2020 y donde 214
personas perdieron la vida y más de 6
mil resultaron heridas en medio de estas
protestas se registraron enfrentamientos
con la policía en las cercanías del
parlamento según informó la cruz roja
libanesa decenas de personas resultaron
heridas en estos altercados y es que las
explosiones del puerto de beirut
golpearon también la arquitectura de la
ciudad pues arrasaron con buena parte de
los edificios históricos responsables
del encanto de esta capital libanesa un
año después de la tragedia se han
renovado algunos edificios gracias a la
acción de ongs especializadas
en el corazón de la capital libanesa el
prestigioso museo sur shock es uno de
los edificios tradicionales más dañados
por las explosiones en el puerto de
beirut
después de un cierre forzado de dos años
poco a poco está volviendo a la vida
la destrucción fue enorme después de las
explosiones sobre todo en el edificio
principal en el sótano y en las obras de
arte recibimos el apoyo de la fundación
ad lift y del ministerio de cultura
francés lo que nos permitió realizar
renovaciones
cerca de un centenar de edificios
históricos resultaron dañados tras la
explosión en el puerto es el caso de
esta casa donde vive el padre y brian
cashman
a él le ayudaron a sucesiones
especializadas en la restauración de
edificios patrimoniales
en mi casa resultó muy afectada por las
explosiones del 4 de agosto estaba
inhabitable no había muros y el techo
dejaba pasar el agua beirut heritage y
ni siquiera ha trabajado durante tres
meses para que en la medida de lo
posible la casa recupere su carácter
tradicional tal vez
las autoridades libanesas hicieron un
catastro de los daños unas semanas
después del desastre pero los
propietarios se quejan de que aún no han
recibido ninguna ayuda estatal
hace aproximadamente un año los
militares vinieron a inspeccionar las
instalaciones nos prometieron ayuda pero
fueron las asociaciones de la sociedad
civil las que realmente ayudaron con las
reparaciones
de conciliar acta del deseado
pero evites iniciative y otras ongs han
logrado reparar el 30 por ciento de los
edificios históricos de beirut
el resto sigue destruido o inaccesible
en más de la mitad de los casos fueron
los propietarios quienes realizaron las
reparaciones en el resto fueron las
asociaciones que trabajaban en el
terreno incluida beirut herbie touch
initiative las que hicieron el trabajo
para ello nos hemos asociado con otras
fundaciones la unesco por su parte
financió la rehabilitación de edificios
protegidos pertenecientes al estado
y hablemos ahora de los juegos olímpicos
de tokio el colombiano anthony zambrano
ganó la medalla de plata en los 400 son
metros planos por otra parte por primera
vez desde 2004 la final de voleibol
masculino no tendrá a brasil como una de
sus protagonistas la selección rusa que
compite bajo la bandera del comité
olímpico de ese país derrotó a los
sudamericanos
los rusos se medirán al vencedor del
partido entre francia y argentina y
competirán por la mañana la medalla de
oro el día sábado
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continúa con nosotros
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde julio de 2020